pseudo-class a way to style an element
based on a change to its state for
example when you hover over a button in
the browser it automatically adds this
hover keyword to the selector when
working with pseudo classes it can be
useful to go into the browser inspector
and force the state on the element
you're targeting there are a bunch of
different pseudo classes out there like
focus when the user is actively using a
form input or disabled when a button has
the disabled attribute set to true
pseudo classes are also useful when
working with a collection of elements we
can easily target the first or last
element in the list relative to its
other siblings at this level by
targeting in the first child or last
child pseudo classes if we want to be
more specific we can use last of type so
it only targets this type of element but
what if we want the second third or
fourth element in that case we can use
nth child and pass an argument for the
element that we want to grab or instead
of a specific number we might want to
use odd or even or maybe we want to grab
every fifth element in the list multiply
5 by n to get every 5th element like 5
10 15 and so on you can also use
addition and subtraction here to create
any kind of pattern you want now
sometimes you might select something in
your CSS but what you actually want to
style is everything else for that we
have the non pseudo class which performs
negation notice how when we hover over
an element in this list all the other
elements are styled but not the actual
element that we're hovering over that's
because we're targeting all the elements
that are not hovered pseudo selectors
are especially powerful when working
with forms one of my favorites is focus
within which allows a parent element to
see if one of its children has focus and
that's especially useful if you have
something like a drop-down menu and once
you keep it open after the user has
clicked a button if you're building a
web app with an international audience
you might want to know about fileting
selector use it to apply custom styles
to any element that has a Lang attribute
you can use it to make all of your Dutch
text orange or combine it with int child
to make your German text black red and
yellow this has been pseudo classes and
100 seconds hit the like button if you
want to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one